hey everybody gamespot's live show
continues here at e3 2014 up on the
Samsung stage I'm Sean McGinnis and i'm
joined by saks who's here to tell us a
little bit about project sparks good to
see you again Chum alright so a project
sparked this game that's been available
for a little while now but you guys are
kind of continually working on it right
because it is that kind of game where
you just you're continually adding
features and it's growing more and more
as time goes on right yeah we've been
out in beta for about three months now
on xbox one and Windows 8.1 and we've
had like an unbelievable like outpouring
of creativity we have over a million
craters now which is way more than we
could have ever hoped for at this stage
like we were trying to hide the bait a
little bit make sure a service held up
the sort of thing right but we've had
like people have been seeking us out
like an Xbox like no tomorrow we have
about 700 new games on average yet every
every day and people spend like majority
of the time making stuff like 75 percent
of the time people spend in creation and
twenty-five percent in playing and the
playing includes testing my own games it
just shows like I really paid up doctors
that really really really want to create
that's that's fantastic that's what
we're hoping for right frankly yeah do
you ever know like it's a little
frightening to make a game where you
don't make the game you make the thing
to make the game right right that's
really what spark is yeah came about
making games yeah let's pull back for a
second there talk about the game in
broader terms what did you guys
originally set out to do with project
spark what what is the toolset that
you're giving people well I've been
making games for about 20 years and I
always thought like the feeling I get
when I make something it's incomparable
like it what is what makes me come back
to work everyday and what makes me just
drive harder and harder add at this this
particular like into PR piece of
entertainment is just so amazing because
you get to entertain people like there's
not a lot of things we get to entertain
people so we said what if we can give
that power to like to the users like
people love games they spend like so
much time playing games like
ninety-seven percent of kids over age
three play games and people don't stop
playing games like we're sort of way
past the kid like games are for kids
right
now it's like the Billy is knowing i'm
over 40's Oh play games i'm pretty sure
i'm not that weird so giving people like
something where they can actually make
their own game so it's just a huge goal
of us hmm and so let's talk about the
tool set that's in there because you
know the ability to make games can go in
a lot of different place you can go real
real deep down certain avenues what sort
of approach have you taken in terms of
like the amount of trent you know just
the amount of tools that you give people
so we try to say you need to be able to
make real games right so need to be
peepin of people can make the game they
always dreamt about making right so it
it set the bar for if we can make pretty
much every genre then we still have work
to do on the flip side if we try to give
people some unbolting onto onto the
tools and try to help them as much as we
can so we try to introduce a swath of
things you can go as deep as you want or
you can stay as high level if you want
basically like choose your own adventure
on one side of it play somebody else's
game and remix it or just go from
scratch and just make your own stuff
right I believe we had a little bit of
footage going there a second ago so so
the things we're showing here like we
showed that last III that's when we
announced and we bring into the show
it's multiplayer which is what we're
seeing there good timing so multiplayer
for us like we knew we needed to get
there but this is it was a very
complicated thing like basically making
a multiplayer version of Photoshop and
Maya and your favorite game engine right
and all at the same time where you can
free form and make creations here we see
somebody else's painting and making the
forest while somebody else is sculpting
somebody else's painting and I can be
making the terrain while you're painting
right on top of me or somebody's putting
down props right on top of that yeah and
it's it's like half trolling have half
collaboration here's what we know now
it's way faster to destroy than it is to
create right see that's deep like the
multiply it's just a core of what we
wanted to achieve the second thing that
we're bringing these different themes
like we're trying to expand on we showed
like a sci-fi sorry we showed a like a
like a fantasy inspired set last year
like storybook plan
and this year we're bringing sci-fi also
to expand what people think about spark
what's important right that you want to
inspire people to make the game they
always wanted and not everybody wants to
work with goblins and trolls so we have
like these Cody ins we have to sci-fi
like these really cool building sets we
have we have we've shown in the trailer
that we're gonna have these massive
freighters like it sort of any scale
anything you want to do with sci-fi
we're gonna we're gonna start showing
you all right now I one of the funniest
things I remember about project spark
was we met back in February or march or
so during the height of the flappy bird
phenomenon yeah and you actually showed
me somebody had made a flappy bird game
in project spark which was kind of kind
of mind-blowing how quickly they turn
that around I think like what we're
proud that we had flappy bird clones
just as fast as Android and iOS yes yeah
so that's a good thing about having a
publishing platform where anybody can
publish on to we saw the first version
of flappy bird almost instantly but what
I really liked was I can compared when I
went and checked out on the other
platforms like what did people do with
flappy bird on iOS first yeah they do
cause a lot of it got really really
creative really fast and use some of the
unique things about spark and didn't
just do like a flat-out recreational
flappy bird and people just went off
right and just made like parodies and
completely different added abilities to
them some of them made them like just
impossible flappy bird some of them made
him super super easy some of them made
cheats like you know I mean like there
was just a million different variations
and then whenever we see people get
inspired by anything that's what we see
we put out a call out of Twitter just
for the fun of it doing super bowl where
somebody made the we didn't have time we
didn't have the money for this ad huh so
here we going to show you the
storyboards for the ad within that money
for so we said wonder if somebody could
make this for us right and in a couple
of days later somebody made the entire
realized version of that story board
like up the entire ad that the people
didn't have money to do during the Super
Bowl right it's pretty nice fun yeah so
what do you think is what have been the
most surprising creations for you what
is something that's just totally blown
your mind
I'd accept the depth of some of it so
liquid this way like with three months
in yeah we've taken three years to make
spark to what it is today and in three
months like we are seeing people coming
out with what they term their alphas I
just looked at a turn-based strategy
game that is inspired by the sort of the
final fantasy 7 era of offer of P by P
geez with like a great beginning to a
story like a fully realized combat
system like including all upgrades
leveling like pops potions like all the
things you would want in a real-time
strategy game in three months that just
seems inconceivable right somebody asked
me to do something in three months yeah
like I would ask for team of 50 right
right like what our community is just on
unbelievable stuff the other thing is
people tell like every genre like
somebody like a particular fond of of
adventure games from the like late 80s
Early 90s of the sort of the
point-and-click style adventure we go to
tell a story and you get a mission you
go here and you go there sort of the tim
schafer style of adventure games huh
we've seen some super funny really well
realized pretty adventure games already
appear right and I would say this is
people scratching the surface because
they've only had three months that's a
scary bit do you find that there's a
much of a discrepancy between like
modern kind of like action-heavy games
versus people trying to like relive
games of their past and go down those
nostalgia trips yeah I i think the like
the $60 amazingly polished you piece
I'll you be stopped style experience
right you know like they will served
already like that lots of other genres
that are not particularly well served on
consult adventure game is a key one
night yeah I and D boppy cheese like of
sort of the like the great squag style I
like Secret of Mana like that that style
there's not a lot of that today on
consoles I think that's what that's it
that's the style that people to set on
very fast I think it's going to expand
like sci-fi we we're shipping a
first-person camera that is a lot more
polished than the first one we put out
in the early beta and just to see how
people react
it it has a lot of the sort of the
modern functionality of what you want in
the first person shooter just to see how
much does that appeal to people this is
one of the genres we have seen very very
few games has been first person shooting
this that's two reason for that maybe
one is people don't care yeah and they
just have plenty of first-person
shooters already sure or it's just that
that we haven't given them quite enough
tools to go and realize that hmm and
clearly you guys have amazing beard
technology as well as though it's funny
we call it be a technology because the
beards auto height when you put a helmet
on people like one of the stuff we like
we try to do is to make it easy for
people to when we put like a sci-fi
helmet on and there's no room for the
beard will auto hide it when you change
your hair the be a tent with it just
like all the beards work on different
head shapes like beer technology is not
an easy thing I know the beards are
difficult man they're dead tricky they
have a mind of their own you're running
like so this is the like hold up
marketing trailer sort of the the thing
that that people have never seen sparked
before that is sort of a great way to
introduce them into water park all about
for with what we love about that trailer
is it's about two people creating
together and finding their vision
together yeah sorta both showing off and
competing and doing stuff like together
that's that's very much for what we hope
to inspire people to do is to get
together and go hey I'm pretty good at
making behaviors I know you can make
some that's really pretty and you like
you look like a good design that you
want to be the guy then that figures out
how to lay out the level and you get
together in these multiplayer sessions
and just sort of lay it out right how
challenging it was it for you guys
creating the technology that allows two
people to create simultaneously because
I'm sure there's a lot of factors that
need to be adjusted on the fly to make
sure that you know these things are in
sync yeah we like we said we try to set
like a realistic path or like what do
people actually want to do so I first
thought was that we would lock out an
area and if I was working in the
southeast corner nobody else could be
close to me yeah and it just didn't it
wasn't gonna work so we said actually
what we want is everybody can do
everything at the same time right on top
of each other so right now I can a demo
here is that I go in and I raise the
terrain on to the guy standing then
the same time somebody's painting in as
fast as they can write as the terrain is
shooting off and the third guys just
putting on trees on top of it as it's
growing that was that's the bar like
everything needs to come right in there
so it's it's certainly it's not an easy
task but we use we use a sure so like
the like the Microsoft cloud and oh you
have live to help with like to help with
keeping track of all this stuff now like
at the show floor we wanted the only
highwire acts that actually use my full
multiplayer going to a show that's no
cheating that's tough with the internet
connection here at this is the first
time we're testing it and it's
nerve-racking but that's what's working
out right I think we need it we really
wanted people to see what it was going
to be like because in the office we are
giddy like this is what we do we sit
down on my desk I have two machines that
are always up and people sit down and we
immediately do the same thing every time
we somebody start sculpting the other
guy starts painting and a third cut
start rolling I think that I'm the third
that like it takes skill to troll well
right of course it's a talent it's a
talent that I've honed over a long
career of trolling yes so where are you
guys at right now with develop and with
development and where do you guys want
to be what do you you know what features
are you planning to add where are you
guys headed we will release fully this
fall like so one point oh and take the
beta tag off this phone what'swhat's
gaining that is multiplayer needs to get
stable and it's this is a big big step
for us is to get here we we're showing
two player here we need for player and
is is our goal is for player multiplayer
and pretty stable and then we need
sci-fi to to be ready to release our
second team and then we need to squash
about 3,500 bucks that's that's the next
thing right that's that okay I can see
how that would take a little bit of time
well if the fun thing about beta is that
it's getting a good workout every day we
have a great community then it's very
passionate about like like this is what
I would do better this is what I would
do different like white you guys need to
consider this isn't this we're still
taking all that in so when I say 3500
bucks both folks features additions
whatever it is mine but we sort of set
apart knowing this is what we think this
is where we want to go out we want to go
out with like a reasonably
a [ __ ] tested is very difficult with big
big big title and we want to have
multiplayer that's a that's a big deal
once you're ready we're ready they'll
come out on xbox one and Windows 8.1 and
then we'll see what goes from there all
right sex well I wish you the best of
luck with all 3500 items on that list
well you can come help us if you want to
sure maybe I probably i'll just end up
trolling you what you know i'm sure that
helps in some small way yes alright well
thanks again for dropping by the samsung
stage here at the game spot live booth
at e3 2014 we're going to cut to a quick
break and be back with even more stay
tuned